hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet in this little clip me and
dr rupee from the doctor's kitchen are
talking about how to avoid burnout now
dr rupee is a hospital doctor who then
became an internet sensation celebrity
entrepreneur by giving people advice
about healthy living and lifestyles and
food and has published a bunch of
best-selling books has appeared in
multiple tv appearances and he's had a
very intimate relationship with burnout
so we're talking about how we as
students of the craft can avoid burnout
in ourselves i hope you enjoy the clip
so you said that the working working
this sort of gp lifestyle meant that you
got quite burnt out yeah um
what's that like being burnt out
it is
it's where
you go
home at like 7 7 30 p.m and you know
you've got friends who you haven't seen
for a while and you just can't be
bothered and you're not excited about
seeing them even though you really
should be because you know it's been
weeks or whatever
um it's where you don't you lose the
empathy
that is so required in in medicine as
well
um and i felt
that slipping away and that that wasn't
a good position to be in you know
sort of like what we were talking before
when
you've got to do something for a patient
and instead of you
having the mindset of this is a
privilege to work for people in the most
vulnerable state it's like
i've got to do this and this is my job
and i have to do this and there's
another thing to take off the list and
that's never really the way i really
wanted to feel within medicine
obviously you can't be happy joy joy the
whole time in medicine you're obviously
going to have good and bad days and
that's just normal but when it becomes
persistent and insidious throughout your
whole week that was kind of like i need
to i need to take a break from this and
i had the sort of foresight
and the privilege and opportunity to
even do that you know a lot of people
don't have the opportunity and a lot of
my friends for example
were supporting families and they had
mortgages and they had all these other
you know um
pressures on them financially i was
independent and i had the opportunity to
go away and i was like i owe it to
myself i know it to my friends who can't
do this to go out and that's that's sort
of what was the push for me to go abroad
but yeah the burnout was not nice place
and i'm i'm thankful i don't think i've
already had that
since
in some ways like obviously during the
pandemic and stuff but i think because
there was that sort of like collective
energy from everyone being in the same
bucket that kind of like pushed you
through i think it's pandering out now
which is why you're seeing loads of
people leave in droves um but yeah that
was yeah it wasn't a nice position to be
in have you ever been in that
i don't think so no that's why like
because because people do talk about
burnout as like being a thing and i'm
always kind of curious like what does
that feel like yeah because
i kind of said to a friend of mine one
point like i don't think i've ever been
burnt out she was like uh you probably
have but you just don't realize it i was
like okay fine let me yeah what does it
mean to be burnt out yeah um i don't
think i have do you have the ability to
cop compartmentalize
yes yeah yeah
because there's a really good podcast
called how to take over the world okay
um you should definitely check it out so
they they they examine uh different
leaders across time and history it's
usually people who have passed away
um but you'll find more recent leaders
like steve jobs i think they did putin
as one as one and one of the recurrent
themes um that i've noticed and actually
the the host notices as well
is the ability to complementalize
different issues so napoleon was able to
put things in one drawer shut it and
then open another one without really
thinking about the last draw that he's
he's closed
i'm learning that skill now but i
definitely didn't have that
when i was working as a gp and i think
perhaps that's maybe the reason why you
haven't experienced it um
but certainly you know my my in my
inability to focus on one thing at a
time is probably why i i got burnt out
and it kind of spilled out into my
personal life right it's built into your
personal life meaning so uh
relationships not really working out um
not being there for my friends
not having the energy to do stuff at the
doctor's kitchen for example putting
things off not being there for my family
all those different pressures i think
that's kind of like yeah how it played
out for me yeah do you think that was
inevitable given the schedule you were
on or do you think there's stuff that
you could have done at the time to kind
of mitigate those kind of personal
spillover effects oh yeah definitely i
think certainly now given what i do
with all the different strands to the
business and how i haven't really
outsourced much
you know running the podcast writing the
books doing the recipes starting the app
running the tech team doing the customer
service doing the charity stuff all that
kind of stuff i've i'm able to flick i'm
still learning this as a skill but i'm
able to
flick from different roles and positions
relatively easier
easily compared to how it was before and
also having a partner who's pretty
regimented about look it's 6 30 pm
you can't be on your computer that late
at night and you haven't spoken to me
for eight hours that kind of keeps me on
the straight and narrow as well so i'm
actually very thankful that i've got
someone who can understand the grind and
the you know the the sort of need to be
there and hustle but also he knows when
i need a bit of rigidity to like be like
you need to stop this and i need to pull
you away hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye